hey guys quick note my brand new book
the authoritarian moment is out
this week go pick up a copy today i
think it's really important
it's about how all of the major
institutions of american society have
now been
taken over and weaponized by the left
against dissent
it's not just about how they did it it's
about how we take those institutions
back
check out the link in the description
below and get a copy of the
authoritarian moment
meanwhile the biden administration is
struggling because the reality
of the biden administration is they need
a successful economy in order to
ram through their gigantic spending
agenda at least in popular
fashion well the economy is beginning to
stagnate
the u.s economy grew at about 6.5
in q2 there's only one problem virtually
all economists thought it was going to
grow at 8.5 percent
and if you recall just a couple of
months ago they thought it was going to
grow in excess of 10
so it is not growing at the rate that
they want it to grow that's not stopping
the media from feigning enthusiasm
you've got cnn business
saying the u.s economy in the second
quarter expanded at a slower rate than
expected
but still its fastest pace since last
fall growing at a seasonally adjusted
annualized rate of 6.5 percent
their headline by the way at cnn
businesses u.s economy just posted the
largest jump in growth since 2020.
uh yeah that's not the headline the
headline is not the largest jump in
growth since 2020.
the headline is you missed your mark by
in terms of real gdp the economy has now
recovered and that it has grown bigger
than its pre-pandemic size but does
anyone feel
that the economy is really at that rate
the answer is no because
gdp is being racked up by government
spending
it's being held up by the amount of
government spending that's being done
the the national bureau of economic
research designated the pandemic
recession as the shortest on record
saying it lasted just two months march
and april of 2020 which is when the
shutdowns were
in normal time says cnn business 6.5
growth
would be a reason to celebrate it's
still pretty good performance but
it's disappointment compared with the
8.5 growth rate economist had forecast
it was only a little change from the
first quarter when the economy grew an
annual rate of 6.3
which by the way is kind of amazing
because you'll remember that something
happened between the first quarter of
this year and the second quarter of this
year
namely the mass vaccination of americans
and yet nothing is changing
which suggests two things one the biden
administration's constant drum beat of
doom and gloom
with regards to the future of the virus
and their unwillingness to acknowledge
that the pandemic no longer has public
health ramifications means that people
are staying home
and two when you pay people to stay home
and then spend
trillions of dollars on nonsensical crap
you end up
actually subjecting the us economy to
headwinds that it can't fully overcome
according to cnn itself the acceleration
in the recovery was spurred
was spurred by consumer spending not
least spurred by the last round of
stimulus checks
as well as the reopening of the economy
and continued vaccination consumers
spent more on services particularly on
dining out and traveling driven by the
same dynamics measures of inflation
through rose throughout the spring for
example the price index that tracks
personal consumption
rose to 6.4 percent in the second
quarter that was its highest level
since 1982 since 1982
even if you strip out the more volatile
items like food and energy the price
index was at 6.1
the highest reading since 1983. and
here's the thing the federal reserve
cannot can they do not have the stones
to actually jack up the interest rates
in a way necessary to cut down on the
inflation they're not going to do it not
when the economy is this low
if the economy is not faster than this
see if the economy really really
if we were like 8.5 growth or something
then they could say listen
we're growing super fast natural
economic recovery is happening we need
to raise the interest rates a little bit
to prevent overheating and to prevent
price inflation
instead because the economy is growing
slower than expected
they are going to continue to rack up
quantitative easing they're going to
continue
to jack money into the economy and keep
the interest rates at zero
out of fear that they're going to sink
joe biden's economic record here
meanwhile the democrats are so
disconnected from reality that they're
worried that joe biden isn't spending
enough
according to the hill democrats are now
warning that any attempts by moderates
to pare down a 3.5 trillion dollar
spending package
could threaten president biden's top
legislative priority and leave the party
empty-handed so joe biden wants to get
everything done in his
budget package he's got the the
bipartisan infrastructure bill the
trillion dollar
boondoggle which is at least better than
the two trillion dollar boondoggle
they're originally proposing now it's a
trillion dollar boondoggle which still
sucks but is better than the alternative
presumably
then they have their giant budget
package that giant budget package the
3.5 trillion
budget package as you will recall has
been held up by kristen
cinema in the in the senate as well as
joe manchin both of whom look at this
and they're saying this is too much
money
now you've got democrats in the senate
saying we're not going to vote for the
infrastructure package
if you don't vote for the for the 3.5
trillion dollar
package and not just that joe biden now
is saying that he wants
immigration reform in the budget package
meaning he wants to legalize
some eight to 10 million illegal
immigrants in the united states in the
budget reconciliation package
by the way the parliamentarian hasn't
even said if you can do that under
budget reconciliation the answer is
probably not but
who the hell knows progressive democrats
are sounding the alarm after kristen
sinema warned wednesday she doesn't
support the 3.5 trillion
price tag for the expansive package
democrats hope to muscle through
biden is saying he's basically
negotiating with her he thinks she'll
end up voting for it in the end but they
may have to cut a few things
democrats hope to move the legislation
on party lines in the senate with
special budgetary rules but
every democrat because they're only 50
of them every democrat can hold this
thing up with one vote
progressives are saying they're going to
hold up the infrastructure plan unless
they get the 3.5 trillion
plan bernie sanders said it's my
absolute conviction you're not going to
have a bipartisan bill
unless you have a reconciliation bill of
3.5 trillion dollars
so as we discussed yesterday joe biden
is now stuck between the progressive
rock and the moderate hard place right
now
the republicans aren't going to vote in
favor of that bipartisan
infrastructure plan at all unless the
democrats pared down the 3.5 trillion
plan and the progressives won't vote for
the bipartisan plan
or the or the budget plan unless they
continue to have it at 3.5 trillion
dollars
sanders says he expects the spending
plan to be 3.5 trillion in the senate
maybe even more
in the house and senator chris murphy of
connecticut adds that any push to
decrease the price tag for the spending
package would make it hard to get the
votes
for it man the democrats are just
cruising for a bruising in 2022 on all
fronts whether we were talking about
these authoritarian lockdown measures
completely nonsensical or whether we're
talking about the vast spending that is
resulting
in reduced and tamped down economic
growth they're just
cruising for it in 2022 which is why
they're so focused in as
always on trump and january 6th because
2022 is looking to be an ugly year for
them 2024 could be even worse especially
if kamal harris is on the ballot
who's got two thumbs and wants you to
like and subscribe